the Joe Rogan experience it's crazy to
even suggest but so is walking into
YouTube shooting a bunch of people then
shooting yourself in the chest that's
crazy to suggest to that people a
[ __ ] mind that [ __ ] was definitely
out of her mind
and also if saw a YouTube video no one
again made no [ __ ] money leave those
videos were terrible well there's no
there's something wrong with that lady's
brain how about her dad goes warn the
police I can't you guys need to check
her out she didn't do something bad do
you do
there's some some issues here but if
you're a cop and they did find her the
night before it 2:00 a.m. because she
went missing they found her and they're
like yeah she doesn't seem like she's
gonna hurt herself or anyone else I
don't know what you want us to do like
we found her she said she's good
sleeping in a car until someone does
something it's so hard to do anything
about it like they they sent that one
college kid they're sending him back
they found his roommates I was we were
talking about it yesterday his roommates
were talking about they were seriously
worried about him he had bleached his
hair blonde start stockpiling ammunition
bought an assault gun and then the cops
came to visit them and and after the
cops left he went out and bought another
AR and they're like okay okay that's it
and there we got it we gotta do
something about this his roommates were
freaking out like people are freaking
out being around the guy and they sent
him back on a technicality because he
wasn't going to school because he
stopped going to class so what can you
do a student visa what they can you know
they deported him oh really yeah Oh
perfect yeah and they said we think we
prevented a tragedy I love that
yeah that's exactly what they should do
I mean however with this lady let's say
they stopped at 2:00 in the morning a
car right and the parent and that the
dad the dad who you know she came from
his seed goes listen she she she's gonna
do something bad we think we've seen
signs we've known her since she was a
day old you guys should do somethin bout
it I don't think you should go how we
talk to her seems all right maybe take
her in for the night you know talk to a
therapist but if she doesn't do anything
and then she does like you people are so
unpredictable look at those eyebrows and
toss her in jail for that video of her
doing those squats and the jumps to
workout video hair board no those eyes
it's crazy that she's not there she
wasn't different playing horror movie
and then up but then and then she's mad
she's not getting frickin revenue
yeah from the YouTube and YouTube's like
your videos suck lady we have nothing to
do I'll see you lazy you didn't come up
in the Open Mic circuit so you don't
have a PhD in psychos all these dudes
that have been in the grind like I
remember I mean Mike's a long time ago
but they're [ __ ] crazy people there's
a certain amount of open microphone E
and they can't get work and they're
angry about it and they're really [ __ ]
crazy
I get on kill Tony when I've been on
like two three times it's perfect
example kill Tony's a perfect example
you go there and you like what in the
[ __ ] am i watching and if someone tries
to tell that person like maybe you
should connect more with the crowd I
connect man connecting this is my best
bits these put your good bits and the
people like what no Tony too long is
like dude you're bombing is they were
laughing their laugh and they laughing
at you and todos they're laughing cuz
you're [ __ ] terrible and we're making
faces behind he goes that's laughing you
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
Tony's like get off the stage
he's like make me it's like oh my god
good boy mmm yeah BC you see that too on
American Idol there'd be some crazy do
like my mom thinks I'm the best you know
the best things lying already and they
get up and it just completely bomb and
then they talk [ __ ] to the experts yeah
you guys just don't know what you want
well you have to look at people as a
whole right now if you look at people as
a whole like physically right there's
people that have built like you and
there's people that have built like
foreign Troyer that's just a fact it's
just it's tough it's tough stuff it's
also brilliant mine
right my point is it's come on seven
it's a roll of the dice that's the same
thing with everything it's the same
thing with your mind as well it just is
the mind varies widely
it varies racially it varies
interracially it varies
age-wise like you're gonna have a 50
year old black guy that's the smartest
guy you ever met in your life and you're
gonna have a 50 year old white guy who
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're gonna have
a 50 year old woman who's out of her
[ __ ] mind and you're gonna have a 50
year old woman who's a brilliant you
know physicist and you're gonna have
everything you know every combination
every combination of smart and stupid
and and the tall and thin people vary
but they also vary with how crazy they
are but also as a variable
I think some people are crazy and then
they find a passion they run with it
maybe it's music comedy but then some of
those crazy people who are different
than the others in high school get made
fun of get bullied and then that
craziness turns into darkness
I mean they get a hold of ak-47 then
that's when you get the mass shootings
oh yeah
there's experiences with those crazy
people and maybe they turn a right
direction and they do something great
right great songs come up with a great
bit or come up with a great TV show yeah
or that person gets bullies so bad the
direction they go into dark is far
higher isn't that crazy mine does crazy
stuff yeah so a hundred percent physical
abuse sexual abuse along with that
medications yeah sure medications could
do it and it's not mean every single
mass shooters on medications but when
you look at the combination of all the
different factors it's like when you see
that lady crying in her car two o'clock
in the morning you're a cop you don't
know what to do what do you what do you
think you think she's gonna like I knew
when I looked at her that she was gonna
go on at YouTube and shoot that place up
no there's no way no there's no way
who's know let's cruise kids same thing
they came to see him two years before
they decided he wasn't a threat and the
people like the FBI is incompetent no 24
months later first of all he probably
got [ __ ] crazier create in 24 months
his mom wound up dying like six months
before that so that probably [ __ ] him
up too there's probably a whole host of
factors in events right but he'd never
did it before how the [ __ ] can you
predict that so that these random
shooters it's a I don't know what you're
gonna do does the only thing with the
YouTube thing is if the dad goes listen
my daughter is gonna do something crazy
and they find her near the YouTube
Northern California offices we should at
least take her in for the night talk to
her and you know that's the least you're
not gonna gonna lose anything taxpayers
be happy to pay for a night in there you
know it's all good yeah I mean I don't
know if that would do it though you know
it's like that lady just seemed [ __ ]
nuts man someone someone said someone
posted it and said be ready to never
sleep again I mean that that'd be didn't
give me that much
yeah theythey I went oh she's batshit
crazy yeah like super duper batshit
crazy thought YouTube was out for cuz
they she was her views were lowering
well one video though she had 45 views
I come on man as [ __ ] bananas I'm
sure they pull our YouTube pages by now
Jamie yeah and if you're gonna go out
right most people do to the head she
shot herself in the chest that's a dark
way to go don't people have done that I
guess people that knew their brain was
gonna get yeah jr. sale did that self in
the chest cuz he goes I want you to stay
in my brain cuz it's not good [ __ ] I
can't feel good no I feel like the brain
people yeah we went dark
we gotta bring it back
[Applause]